now that a group of drag performers of
Turkish Kurdish cypriot and Southwest
Asian heritages are doing their bits to
raise money for turkey and Syria
following the earthquakes and their
fundraising in style with a cabaret so
let's find out a little bit more about
it joining me now is the co-founder of
the Harem of no one Toby kind and also
performers darling and Tahini so good to
see you all all looking fabulous I have
to say making me feel incredibly Dowdy
Toby first of all tell us a little bit
about this fundraiser well
um this fundraiser came as an idea
obviously like after the horrible
disasters hit and we were already going
to have our
monthly show at uh battle green working
Mouse Club at the today
um but like
um following the events we decided very
quickly to change it into a fundraiser
um and
um we have
um friends who are in the field
um who are back in turkey and
um who are in contact with people who
have affected by this disaster
and especially queer people and uh sex
workers who are
part of the most vulnerable group
and they have limited access to
health and basic needs and public
services and Aid as well sadly that's
that's the reports that we're getting
because so you're worried about
discrimination against some groups then
are you yeah in the aid efforts yeah
yeah yeah yes
um that's that's the reports that we're
getting and also the column is still the
star has written uh a thorough article
about it so we've decided to just
support their efforts we're not
activists ourselves but
we are good and one thing that's to
entertain
and to perform so we decided to make a
call for people from our community as
well they have answered
um back
um they have supported our call
fantastic in the show's tonight yes so
tell us a little bit about it what will
you be doing so we are actually two
floor now we have the main stage and we
have downstairs we are with Istanbul
koreat Collective makva meet sons of
times and the
lgbtqia secret diaspora and old beats so
there will be lots of live music singing
and downstairs there will be like a
little bit kind of like a fair that some
art pieces will will be sold for an
auctions right yeah yeah exactly oh
fantastic so it would be like live
performance and then downstairs a little
bit more chill with some art pieces and
yeah and do YouTube perform to get you
all three perform together are you doing
separate acts so we do it together we do
it
the whole night the whole night is a
whole Harem of no one Extravaganza like
we this is what we do we entertain but
we throw shows and we do an important
shattering already as Toby was saying
because our guttering is basically
creating a safe space for everyone and
anyone and also celebrating our culture
in doing that so while doing this
important Gallery we say let's do it
even more important because in this time
we need to
um you know help the ones in need
actually yeah and what do you think that
does for the to the to the mood and the
atmosphere when people they're there to
have good fun you're going to provide a
great show but at the same time it's a
very serious reason behind it do you
think that could affect the atmosphere
at all what do you think
oh that could affect the atmosphere in a
good way I do want to believe and we do
want to help the LGBT people on the on
the earthquake zone so I'm sure that
will affect in a good way so the
motivating factor yeah well it's it's
quite hard to like show up on the stage
and entertain when when there's like
such a a big uh
uh tragedy really uh but uh we also
believe in the power of coming together
um I we think that it's healing and and
the power of
um art
um and we come together with this
motivation really to to do something
well then that's like what we know so we
can't really do anything else that's
that's yeah I thought that that's the
bits we can do even though even though
having fun is kind of like not the
easiest thing after all of this but
there's always we can do for more now
let's put to a good call yeah yeah so
tell us how you all came together in the
first place how many of them you are
there and and it's called The Harem of
No One the room of no one come from oh
yeah I guess tonight will be the
crowdest one as in like performance and
all of us it will be our crowded night
how did we come together well yeah the
the Harem of no one is maybe the name is
not in Twitter at first but uh we were
inspired by the harems of the past where
the the the Emperors had
women had as slaves and they were
confined in in a forbidden palace or or
the like
um but we we took that and we we changed
that uh into Haram of no one so getting
rid of the owners getting rid of the
emperor so that uh it's just us
liberated and we're just creating
um trying to create Beauty
and and challenging stereotypes is that
all part of it as well do you think of
course it is babe I'm staying in front
of you with a beard on
obviously we're breaking boundaries and
also like it's it's one of our things
that like we one of our main point is
that you can be queer you can be from
the swanna region you can be queer I'm
from Cyprus you can be queering from
Cyprus and we're trying to put that out
there because for us being queer
sometimes lines with that your culture
and your space that you grow up it might
not be the most hostile but you can
still be in contact and connected to
your culture so we're trying to put that
out and do you think the message is
getting through do you think attitudes
are changing oh yes I think so because
we're receiving so many great feedback
uh from from people who are attending
our events
um from straight people from queer
people from people from the Kurdish
Community Turkish Community separate
community and also a lot from British
people as well
um so yeah we're we're quite encouraged
by this